okay let's move on to the next one this
one is from
alistair and the question is so we had
lauren kolenzo sample on the show
some number of months ago i've lost
track of of time
but uh she's one of our coaches at
stronger by science and we were talking
about training and she basically
um suggested an idea i don't think she
was like you know
leaning hard into it it's not like her
main coaching philosophy that she's
about to write an ebook about or
anything like that but
she talked about the value in sometimes
rather than doing like
six sets of the same exercise saying
well why don't you just do one set of
six different exercises
and present a more varied stimulus for
the muscle
and so the question here is is there any
reason to believe that changing
exercises
circumvents the diminishing returns
effect of doing multiple sets
yeah so that's a good question uh
and it's not one to which i have a
firm answer but what i will say is that
i think that the the effect of doing
like
multiple different exercises but the
same number of sets
i think that the the net impact of that
would either be
neutral at worst or possibly positive
uh the reason i say possibly positive
is that i'm not sure that it would have
an impact on say just like
total lean body mass accretion or total
like
arm lean mass accretion or anything like
that but there is some evidence
that varying exercises helps
kind of target all regions of a
particular muscle or all muscles within
a muscle group
more effectively so um in
that statement i think like five years
ago would have been completely decried
as bro science but now there's actually
a pretty fair amount of evidence for it
so to start with
um i think probably the first study that
i bring up when having this discussion
is one from fonseca and colleagues in
2014
the title is changes in exercise are
more effective than in loading schemes
to improve muscle strength
and so essentially in that study they
had four groups
one of them so
the way that study worked is it was a
training study with volume increasing
over time
and in one of the groups what they did
is they kept the exercise the same the
whole time the exercise being smith
machine squats
but they varied the load throughout kind
of like an undulating periodization deal
in another group they kept
just the exercise the same only smith
machine squats
didn't vary the load so it was like 80
1rm for every session
uh one of the groups they varied the
exercises
so they had four lower body exercises in
total
smith machine squats being one of them
but i think also
leg press lunges and deadlifts maybe um
so two of the groups they had that
variety of exercises one of them
again used varying loads so kind of like
a undulating periodized approach
and one of them just stuck with about 80
1rm
for every session for those four
different exercises
and so the the net result of that study
is i want to say strength gains were
pretty similar in every group or maybe
they were better in
the groups that varied exercises i don't
remember that one for sure but this
question is about hypertrophy and i do
remember this one for sure
what they found hypertrophy wise they
were looking at quad growth
and essentially like vastus lateralis
growth and just like
generalized quad growth was pretty
similar in all four groups
but the groups that varied exercises
throughout the study had like
better growth in all four heads of the
quads
so like general quad growth was pretty
similar in all of the groups but the
ones that varied exercises
like had more fast as intermediate
intermediate growth or vastus medialis
growth
so like kind of overall well-rounded
quad hypertrophy favored the groups that
varied exercise
even though like generalized quad growth
was probably pretty similar across the
board
so that's that's looking at different
muscles within a single muscle group
there's also some research looking at
regional activation with different
exercises targeting the same muscle
group so
this is this is the piece that a few
years ago people would have decried as
bro
science the idea was basically you know
if you activate
the hamstrings the entire muscle gets
activated and it's probably going to
have a
relatively hyper a relatively similar
hypertrophic effect
all the way up and down the length of
the muscle what we found since then is
there's kind of like
well essentially just that regional
activation is possible
if you activate the hamstrings like the
middle of the hamstrings muscle
the proximal parts of it the distal
parts of it are all probably going to
activate to a similar degree
but based on the exercises you choose
you can have
say greater proximal hamstring
activation or greater distal hamstrings
activation
um based on the different sorts of
exercises you choose
specifically here like hip extension
type exercises
seem to kind of activate the whole
muscle
somewhat equally or maybe slightly more
like the proximal parts of the hamstring
like closer to your butt
and like knee extension type stuff seam
or knee flexion type stuff i mean seems
to activate
kind of the distal portions of it closer
to your to the back of your knee
a little bit more but but that's a
that's a generalizable thing that we
found with different exercises in
different muscle groups
so by varying exercise for the same
muscle or the same muscle group
you may get a little bit more
well-rounded hypertrophy
up and down the entire length of a
muscle instead of just concentrated
at the point that say a particular
exercise would target with regional
activation
this is somewhat this is a bit of an
aside
um but just to illustrate how plastic
muscle fibers are
there was actually a rodent study
which i didn't dig up before recording
this but which andy galpin shared
i don't know maybe a year ago at this
point um
but it was looking at uh myosin heavy
chain
isoform uh densities up and down the
length of an entire muscle fiber so
essentially
like a decent amount of your muscle
fibers aren't just like pure type 2 or
pure type 1 they'll have
like a mixture of type 1 myosin and type
2
mice and heavy chains um and it found
that like
the the amount of type 1 versus type 2
mice and heavy chains can actually vary
up and down the length of a single
muscle fiber
which suggests that like there were
probably some some adaptations
going on that would spur that that like
you know maybe
the proximal or the distal part of that
fiber was getting
generally more work in that mouse's
day-to-day life
so anyway muscles are pretty plastic um
and i do generally think that
varying the exercises you use to target
a particular muscle
will probably give you more well
well-rounded growth down the entire
length of that muscle or across that
entire muscle group
so as i said to start with if you're
just
interested in just sheer total growth
like maybe
muscle volume just as a gross measure of
that entire muscle size
i don't know that varying exercises is
going to affect that so much
i kind of think it will but i'm not sure
about that but i do think it will
probably give you
more well-rounded growth again kind of
across the entire muscle and throughout
the entire muscle group
and i certainly don't think it's going
to be worse for total hypertrophy
now in terms of how you accomplish that
i don't necessarily know that you would
need to do it the way
lauren suggested of like you know
maybe using six different exercises for
one muscle group within a workout
instead of just six sets of one exercise
uh you know it could be you do a four
week block of one exercise and then you
do a four week block of another exercise
and then you do a four week block of
another exercise
or it could be you know if you're
training biceps twice a week
you do uh two sets of three different
exercises on one day and then you do two
sets of three different exercises on the
other day
like i i don't think that you have to
use all of those exercises within one
session there's there's different ways
you could set that up
but i am generally in favor of like
varying the exercises you use
to attack a particular muscle group
again if your primary goal is
hypertrophy
if it's strength then you know you
probably don't want to stray
too far away from the exercises you're
primarily using
to test strength so if you're a power
lifter you should probably be doing a
fair amount of squat bench deadlift
maybe you have some variation in there
but you know probably
the majority or at least a good bulk of
your work coming from
the classical exercises but if your goal
is hypertrophy i think variation's
generally a good thing
and one other possible benefit as well
is just motivation and here different
people are wired differently
some people want a reasonably small
stable of exercises they do
they want to do them all the time they
want to be able to
more directly be able to compare their
performance in this session to
you know the session they just did three
days ago and the session they did four
days before that
etc etc um but
for a lot of people like variety is the
spice of life and they just
you know like to do more exercises and
kind of get bored if they do the same
stuff all the time that doesn't apply to
everyone but it does apply to some
people
um so just to kind of wrap this up and
bring it home
uh varying exercises especially doing a
bunch
for a single muscle group within one
session i don't know that it's strictly
better i think
at worst it's probably about as good as
doing
a bunch of sets of just one exercise but
i do think it is
probably at least somewhat beneficial
for ensuring well-rounded development
of the particular muscle group that
you're trying to target
i should be fair here the uh
example i put forth of doing like six
different exercises
in the same workout that might have been
a straw man
i simply don't remember with a great
deal of detail
exactly the scenario we talked about
with lauren so if if i made an egregious
exaggerated straw man my sincerest
apology